تم وصف Taichi على أنه دواء
متحرك في الصباح الباكر قبل
أن تبدأ الرطوبة حقًا ، سترى
مشاهد مثل هذه في جميع أنحاء المدينة
لقد أتيت إلى Sun yat-sen Park لمقابلة
Linda foon تتحدث عن الأناقة التي كانت
تدرس تاي  تشي على مدى العقد الماضي ،
كانت راقصة باليه محترفة سابقًا من خلال
التجارة ،
كانت تتعاون مع أوركسترا هونغ كونغ
الصينية في عرض يضم
تاي تشي في الربيع ، إنه جميل
للغاية ، أعني فقط أن
أشاهدك ، إنها صفقة أشعر بالاسترخاء.  لا
أعرف كيف يكون هذا تحديًا جسديًا شديدًا ،
فأنت تفعل ذلك ، إنها
صعبة ربما عندما لا
تفهم وعندما تكون مبتدئًا ،
ولكن عندما تبدأ في ممارستها يكون أكثر
تمرينًا رائعًا أو رقصة جميلة لا تصدق ، لذا
سنذهب سانجاي  لبدء تمرين بسيط للغاية
، حسنًا ، مهما فعلنا ،
نبدأ بالإعداد الذي
يحدد النغمة وكيف نمارس بشكل جيد
حتى بالنسبة لأبسط تمرين حتى
نبدأ بالوقوف بشكل مستقيم معًا
وجفون العين دائمًا الرأس
مستقيمًا ، والظهر دائمًا مستقيم لأن
الطاقة يجب أن تنتقل ، يجب أن تخرج
الطاقة من الخلف ، حسناً ،
تخيل أن لديك هذا الأكورديون
ولديك كرة من الطاقة بالداخل
وأنت تتنفس وتتنفس للخارج
عندما تتنفس ، تتوسع ثم
تتنفس ، فقد أظهر البحث الوثيق
أن تاي تشي يمكن أن يفيد
توازن قوة العضلات والمرونة حتى يساعد في
تقليل التوتر وخفض ضغط الدم
الآن نحن نغلق هذه الأشياء في القدم الأخرى
معًا ونحن قريبون
عندما تكون في هذا يعني العودة إلى
أصل
ذلك ، فنبدأ وننتهي ثم نبدأ
هي دورة رائعة ،
أشعر أنني أريد أن أتعلم
التدرب والاستمرار في القيام بذلك ،
فهناك ذلك العقل والجسد  نوع من الشيء بمجرد أن
تبدأ في الشعور به ، أعتقد أنه لا لبس فيه
لأنه الآن يعمل عقلك
وجسمك بالتركيز في نفس
الوقت الصحيح
، يكون ليانغ ويانغ لديك توازن لذلك
عندما تحقق هذا التوازن في العقل ، فإن
الجسم  عندما يكون لديك الجزء الآخر
بداخلك في وئام واحد يحدث
التحول ينفجر